all right here's a fascinating poll um
highlighted by michael moynihan of vice
news and but this is a poll from 1997.
and this is when i was in like fifth or
sixth grade um and this is what the
polling data on race relations said
back in 1997. the article says nearly
nine out of ten black teenagers said
racism has little impact on their
day-to-day lives according to a time cnn
poll released on sunday the survey also
found more than half of all teenagers 62
percent of blacks 58 whites believe
racism is a big problem asked about
racism in their own lives 89 of black
teenagers said racism was a small
problem or not a problem at all
now you see that
and
at first it's kind of shocking because
it's unthinkable
that a poll like that would have similar
results today
you just you can't imagine a poll of
black teenagers 2022 and it comes back
that 90 percent are saying that racism
is not a problem we're only a small
problem in their day-to-day life
yet for those of us who lived through
the 90s it's actually not surprising at
all because race was not an issue in the
90s like it is now
i'm not saying it was perfect
okay and i made this point on twitter
and there are a lot of people that
responded so what are you talking about
what about the rodney king riots and
what about oj and all this yes all that
happened
we're not saying that it was perfect
that there was perfect harmony that we
were living in a post-racial utopia no
one is saying that that's never going to
happen it's impossible
um what i'm saying is that in the 90s
that's when we got the closest to
racial harmony
that we've ever been
and we've been going backwards ever
since
which isn't to say that it was perfect
but we got as close as we're going to
get
9 out of 10 black teenagers in the 90s
saying that racism does not affect their
daily lives that proves the point
and again it doesn't surprise me because
i was a kid in the 90s and i could
remember that this just was not it's not
that race never came up but it wasn't
this overriding
concern it wasn't suffocating everyone
and you could tell jokes and there were
you know and you could just
kind of live your life and and you
didn't have racial issues constantly
shoved down your throat
and there was not this focus
even in the school systems
on convincing kids you know if you're a
black kid well convincing them that
you're oppressed you're a victim
there was a little bit of that not
nearly like there is today
there wasn't nearly as much white guilt
foisted on the the white kids if you're
a white person then you're
automatically a racist
you have to beg forgiveness for what
your ancestors allegedly did
so compare that to uh today i couldn't
find this exact question asked in the
last year or two but you could piece it
together from other questions there was
a gallup poll in 2021
showing how many black versus white
americans say that race relations are
good
either somewhat or very you know
only 33 of black said that we have good
race relations in america in 2021 43 of
whites
in 2001 that number was 70
for blacks 62 for white
so 20 years ago black people in this
country according to the polling had a
better view of race relations than even
white people did
but a majority of everyone agreed that
race relations are pretty good
um
there was another question is racism
widespread this is now 2021.
84 of black adults said yes it is 59 of
white
so 90 of black teens in the 90s said
racism had little or to no impact on
their daily lives
which which means we can assume that
they didn't think that it was widespread
if it doesn't have any impact on your
day-to-day life then it's not as
widespread
but now nearly as many black americans
say that it's a widespread problem what
this means is that
those you know we're talking about black
teenagers versus black adults
so those teenagers growing up in the 90s
said well you know it's not that big of
a deal it doesn't affect my everyday
everyday life
since then
they've been convinced
otherwise
and that's because there has been a
concerted effort on the left
to
destroy all of the progress that had
been made
and to take us backwards
i realize that racial strife and
disharmony is better for them easier to
exploit
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there